we just saw Deadpool - yeah this gave me
exactly what I wanted
oh man yeah I can't this is gonna be
like this is gonna be the easiest
everywhere ever ever and we went in
expecting something and we got it and is
it the greatest thing on planet Earth no
but it's exactly what I expected yeah
tenet that that's us
I'll save this because I kind of said
the first thing about the first movie
everyone's like what are you crazy
waiting to fly it's like again but we're
in the age of I like it means you hated
it for whatever reason but there was
something I realized watching this one
because one of my issues with the first
film not issue but I said if we're gonna
break the fourth wall so much when we
try to go serious like so dark and so
serious you know do the tones really mix
because then I'm always thinking like a
watch you do this fourth wall joke to
get out of that and stuff but I realized
that I think when you do combine the two
like that when you get into the really
serious moments are the extreme action
and stuff like that it makes the funnier
moments all the more funny because you
don't know when they're coming and I'm
thinking like the big action scene with
you know the trucks and everything and
I'm thinking that was the best thing in
the movie yes
yeah it's twice that uh I mean I I guess
this isn't technically MCU but it's a
Marvel property so it's twice a Marvel
property this year has been saved by a
car chase cuz Black Panther was the same
thing - that was the best action
sequence and built in Black Panther as
well was that car chase in the middle so
no chases saved by and actions if it was
pretty good even without the car okay
yeah the finale was not the strongest
part oh you mean like okay I got I'm
trying when it comes to the action
sequences yeah Black Panther was saved
by that car chase when I came into the
action I'm not saying that it didn't
have anything else going for him but
that was a fantastic movie that's also a
good action even if you took
but I was definitely like at the center
the the show style that good action but
that that yeah that was the centerpiece
like yeah that was like it cool yeah it
was also the funniest when it came to
the action too it had the most laughs I
thought yeah the the I mean that the
plot is cow what you see in the trailers
where he's gonna go he comes across this
kid and wants to stop this guy named
cable comes back from the future
you know the Killam and he wants to save
the kid it's cut Terminator honestly
Terminator 2 exactly yeah because of
John Connor yeah
let you serve all the jokes of
referencing they always say that like
even somebody quotes a line and both you
just go the trouble copy just yeah
Robocop and yeah it's still bloody it's
still gritty it still got a lot breaking
the fourth wall Joe that's what I like
the most is as freaking hardcore well
I'm still merciless which I love I love
the intro to he's like just go and he's
like going through the opening credits
oh this is like oh yeah we got all this
stuff and see that guy that guy's really
unfired that's that CGI we literally lit
that guy's fire he's running across the
screen like in flames you know and again
I feel like this is a better x-men movie
than the x-men movies this is still the
best series of x-men movies we've got I
suppose Logan now it like we could count
that but if you take Logan out of it
like yeah these are the two best x-men
films we've gotten probably okay I do
like first class yeah I would go these
two Deadpool movies Logan and first
class those are your four best x-men
movies out of how many do we have like
it's 1 million
I don't know and the scene cave was he
okay like with the x-men movies like I
finally gotten to a point where it's
like okay I just feel like I don't need
to get excited or anything for our made
more because it's just no more
characters to see and then it's like
there's cable and I'm just like god
dammit
Josh Brolin is playing cable and he just
it does a great job again I mean like I
said that dude can do no wrong Oh zip it
then
yeah it's one of those things where it's
like I kind of got those goosebumps
again when it's like oh yeah like I
remember like that excitement of x-men
and it's like I don't really get that
too much from the movies but I get it
more from Deadpool you know like when
the Blackbird comes in and here comes
Colossus and Here Come wanna know why
because Bryan Singer is so slow you
direct slothful every single x-men film
we directed is slow as fuck well that's
a I actually do not slow as Superman
Returns but it's like and then you've
got the let me come into the University
and then you've got freaking Brett
Ratner doing the third one where that
movie's problem wasn't it was slow is
just a train wreck in every other regard
and then first class is the only one
that I thought oh this is what I wanted
out of x-men it's the only one that
feels closest to deadblow in spirit
where it's like yeah
youthful teenage energy riding on a
messy jumping out doing cool stuff
hasn't dated 60s metaphor for racism
it's not this and I actually don't hate
any of the x-men but we take such of
origins that the only one is just
diehard hate and they make some great
jokes again with that there's just very
Wallace and bye-bye I know that's a no
put it best who's not like x1 and x2 out
of those original three x2 is the best
but there's still just something about a
met it's just lacking a certain some
well and now you have these movies that
are allowed to be kind of x-men but it's
like it's too late you know for like the
x-men movies to do it and they just run
out of steam oh we've got a serious idea
now yes I so now we have this Deadpool
which was like - it's like well I mean I
know Wolverines a main character it
still felt like well it's not all the
xmin there here's a couple of the major
characters doing something on the side
well the other x-men are dead now I
guess well tell them there's a boring
direction there's a mutant that that's
like kept in a prison he's like the
biggest mutant there and I was kinda
like I know we're guessing we were
guessing and then when they reveal that
like oh yeah oh yeah because that's what
the x-men movies did because they just
got soul
lost and then they tried to restart
again and now they're lost again and it
seems like Deadpool is the only one
that's like let's just do the cool stuff
that was cool about it
yeah and yeah Ryan Reynolds is still
having a ball there is no actor credits
equal but they're stuck during the
credit Hey
but that whole bit about how this film
was brought to us by 15,000 people who
it's like an anti-piracy ad that was
amazing yeah we're just waiting for
distributed legally um and I'll honestly
maybe that was the most Deadpool thing
in the movie cuz I was like wow I didn't
see that coming yeah fucking anti-piracy
- during the credits their stuff and it
was very funny oh no honestly the
credits I don't know how I'm gonna put
this cuz out of people jumping on me I'm
just gonna say it redeems the movie in a
certain way because they do something
that was like you better not and I'm
like oh good they didn't cuz the credits
redeemed it but well we got to see where
they're go I see the credits kind of
again you know this is a studio choice
where they're like you know leave little
open maybe we wanna do something with
these characters but maybe I'm I'm
against what they did in this movie when
I came to a couple of choices with it I
am near the opening at two here I'm
gonna marry again so I am completely
okay if they're just like F fucking now
we were just joshing in there like I
like if that was a studio choice like
now keep your options open then maybe
the one good thing the studio did kind
of weird that there again I mean I think
you know people are gonna like you know
dying this is stuff it's a little way
that they're kind of confirming there's
an afterlife we get to the end no that
could be anything
no no as decision that D I don't know if
ever felt like there pretty much
confirming it you know what Doug when
it's all said and done Deadpool is a
story about accepting Jesus sister
okay and they use the term family
picture they did family that's funny
close enough
we'll take credit the sound the
soundtrack was great I think that was my
favorite when they do like the whole
omen thing except they just go shit
balls
my favorite was the use of Oz voices
play at dolly
at 9:00 to 5:00 during an action say
actually just this big actually that was
the best use of nine to five cents
magnify movie I saw that movie again
when they did the the fathom re-release
every beverage like that movie still
freakin hilarious oh I love them yeah uh
I will say this is not the best use of
take on me since we'll ever since the
original take out me yeah this is
actually a really good sound check
oh like every every song choice at all
even the Celine Dion song which oh yes
like you know its own trolling thing but
it really works in the way that they use
it they use it for the opening credits
and it's great
the I was guessing we saw this on IMAX I
see no reason to see it on IMX like okay
fine but like it's not actually I
actually disagree but I didn't think it
would be worth seeing it on IMAX and I
think the highway chase sold it for me
as I'm like you know what this is way
more fun an IMAX where I can really see
everything in a members it's not quite
dark night flip the truck worthy but I
am II may was definitely I'm just like
alright I was like now I I'm not gonna
say if you're not seeing an IMAX you're
completely missing out but I don't
regret paying the extra money you know
that is I think coming off of infinity
war where the whole film was young for
IMAX it took up the whole screen and
that was the last thing I thought I Mac
said that could mean I don't think you
need to obsess over seeing it in IMAX
but I don't regret seeing and I didn't
come out of there like boy I really
didn't need to see that night max thank
you madam alike oh that was pretty cool
IMAX like it is I've seen way to see
better but like it
I felt like it's justified the price you
know just enough not like oh my god but
you know and again the two probably two
of my favorite jokes and this actually
do do involve x-men teams the first one
is just asking why's it always Colossus
and the other girl they're the only ones
holding everything I won't give it away
but it's probably we got it and we'll do
a spoiler corner I know we get some of
the jokes I mean well that was that was
one of the best jokes the devil is okay
okay hands just read jokes we will do a
spoiler corner because we lost our shit
for a good minute at that okay I feel I
think the rest of the Chrome's looking
bad and then the other one also involves
the the x-force and their first mission
and yeah I won't give it away we'll talk
about spoiler corner but Lady Luck by
the way is like Domino right yeah I love
Domino and her whole like ladybug
superpower and that I feel like that's a
character that could only really work in
this Deadpool you never could what a
worm the combination of silly kick-ass
action and really well really funny
because it's like Squirrel Girl it's
like almost like a joke where it's like
well then you're just pretty much
involving that you know that's what I
like she down I mean like she'll fight
she's like concerned you know other bad
things to happen other people but she's
like whenever she's involved she's like
there's something I see where she's like
falling you know like to her death and
she's just not gonna look you she just
goes ah like that knowing she's gonna
land on something yeah he doesn't what a
great was my favorite like supporting
character in the film and then I also
loved that kid just because it's been a
while it's really good it's been so long
since I've had like we've had like a
terminator to like young John Connor
Eddie for a long sort of role where it's
just some kid who's like fuck you all
laughing might have something kid yeah
it's like this little punchy New Zealand
kid who just doesn't really good yeah oh
yeah yeah okay the one it's not a huge
problem but is the one thing I and I get
why they cut it short but I do wish
there was II
than more of a connection between
Deadpool and the kid like it works movie
we're lucky we got anything here's the
thing because by via the whole thing is
is the kid gonna turn bad you know even
when you meet them he's like doing this
terrible stuff and you get Y and n
Deadpool gets Y and they're really
building up like they want that mystery
of you don't really know and so I think
because of that sort of keeping their
connection minimal makes sense at the
same time it's one of the big emotional
arcs in the film it's like when it gets
serious it is mostly about the two of
them so I would have liked if there's a
little bit more but I got the decision I
got why they did it cuz he still wanted
it to be pretty intense he didn't know
what you know rally was gonna go but yes
I I'm trying to think like there's not
there's not too much it was funny I
think if you approach it more as a dark
comedy yeah it's kind of so people have
to yeah but I mean it does have heart in
it the first one did have some heart in
it but I think of you approaches that
it's perfectly fine like it's a good
movie like it I'm not gonna sit here and
go this is the one I'm gonna remember
till the day I die but it's not
definitely a great laugh again answer
coming up off of like again some really
big companies that come out like in
Fanny Warren and black panther and stuff
you know I mean this there's a part me
it's like that truck the car chase was
so cool and it was so good but there is
a part me I'm like yeah it didn't really
feel like super huge but maybe that's
part of the charm I think coming off of
those two movies in particular it feels
refreshing Lee pointless yeah cuz it's
just like it's like oh no that the
universe I know cables is like well the
futures kind of at stake but it's just
like it's almost vaguely hinted you see
like one shot of him in the future just
like it it's like yes no one today he
really comes out of nowhere which again
it's not like Days of Future past where
you were spending like at least a half
hour of that movie in the future and
seeing this is more just like here we'll
give you like a quick two minutes just
to catch you up and like that was it and
like yeah you had black panther it was
so heavy with all its themes and then
you add like you know infinite
it's like figure the whole universe in
second then here's Deadpool - well the
fight thing yeah I saved this 14 year
old kid who can light shit on fire like
I'm just like you know it's
professionally just kind of yeah it's
pointless like but but it's very it's
low-key but but they are still heavy
scenes in it heavy sentences but they're
like okay we're not gonna have laughs
we're gonna play this you know real it's
a little more intimate well and what's
what's funny is that there's a scene
where I'm arousal it's right at the
cameras as les just lazy writing and
there are a ton of scenes in the layout
of this film particular with the plot in
the story or good like Chauhan is biased
but it's like a movie that can get away
with it because it is referencing it and
I have no words like we know you want to
have some meat to this you want some
substance but you're mostly here to have
fun
I do hope and my only gripe is I hope
they get a little more clever cuz I feel
like so the last one that can come this
is the last we can kind of get away with
like because if it never crosses into
men in black to territory but there were
occasional moments where as weaving into
that okay this is just a sequel and then
it would do something and up the ante
but I'm like okay no no you you you
pulled it out the last second like that
was good that was a funny joke but I
feel like that's the only problem with
Deadpool where if you don't do it right
it's got a limited like timeframe like
it's got a limited usability like you
can only play this card so many times
yeah this was definitely trophy where
it's like haha well you're making fun of
the tropes but you're still using the
tropes hmm you can do that this time but
I feel if we get into a third or fourth
fifth film are you really gonna buy
something dude it's gonna get old pretty
quickly and I'm like I was still okay
with this one but like yeah you'd better
start rethinking this it's a tricky
situation to be in because you want to
still be that funny smaller film that's
just gonna like I say have some meat to
it but just have fun but then you also
want to have something where people want
to keep coming back and see something
bigger they want to see you take the
next step so it is tricky it's tough to
balance
uh but but 74 count a movie - I mean
like I said and not it was funny enough
I'm like if it wasn't funny enough that
I was like oh yeah and like every time I
thought oh really they're gonna do this
like then I would lay off really hard
and I'm like mmm okay you made it work
like you get unlike men in black to
where that didn't happen it was mostly
just like now you're gonna do this and
it's not very funny yeah so that's the
only thing and I'm like they got away
with it here I thought but it's
definitely I think in the future it's
just like okay you're gonna have to
start like getting a little more clever
than you know yeah than just action you
have some dramatic connection to a
person and then fourth-wall jobs and
then just throw in random mutants or
whatever or ones from the last one you
and say you know hey here we go again
you know kinda like that um but yeah I
agree I think this is the last one when
they can kind of get away with that the
third one they gotta I feel I feel like
they're smart enough to know that Ryan
Reynolds are smart enough to know that
like you know the writers be like okay
we gotta we gotta have something we
gotta mix this up a little bit we got to
really really do something that people
either aren't expecting or really takes
a big step but for what this was yeah I
I really enjoyed it the actions cool the
comedy is great there are dramatic
moments too that work the effects for
the most part are really good yeah and
even I use a kind of referencing and now
your big CGI fight yeah says I'm just
like all right that almost gave you the
excuse to not look perfect like I like
when that character is introduced the
first thing I'm thinking is well okay
then you got Colossus in this movie they
better and they do the song that made me
very very happy it's like it's okay to
have a CGI fight with the host - I will
hop that that's totally cool so yeah and
anything else you can play you're set
free pretty short and slug blood guts
action and skids swearing yeah how can
you go wrong
yeah they had a lot of fun I think if
you like the first one you'll probably
like this one - nothing groundbreaking
and
yeah oh and baby dick in a in a dish
now that is been ism and that hasn't
gone through yet is it I don't know I
think they're still negotiating all
right so it's still technically Fox so
the mouse may not have to worry about it
yeah it's LZ mm-hmm very bizarre yeah I
just love to hear that is like the one
or it's like with the environment and
I'm careful people are that was the one
where I was like okay I was legit
surprise III mean I can't really say I
gotta admire the movies balls cuz in
this case I would have to say it
literally but yeah I my jaw hit the
ground that was like I guess you could
get away with it because of the context
ish for your big CGI movement or a
little yeah I don't know I just well say
we talked about that but yeah I don't
know like you've Disney they might still
be negotiating that but I'll tell you if
Disney grabs Fox that's gonna be one
word I could just see the mouse now so
okay so there it is good movie check it
out you like the first one you probably
like this one join us in spoiler corner
which will probably be shorter than this
video but um
you